they are worried about their missing
colleagues a Mudslide at an opencast
copper mine in Zambia buried miners last
week several are believed to be trapped
underground those who escaped show how
they squeeze through narrow tunnels to
get in and out of the mine this one was
on interest so he managed to Escape run
away
Survivor the accident happened at C mine
in chingola about 400 km from the C
capit laka the mine belongs to a local
company that's waiting for safety and
environmental approvals to start formal
operations the owners of these mining
companies should stop enticing our
children to work for only $200 the
government should punish people who
employ our children and expose them to
such harsh conditions government
officials say the Min is still trapped
are in three locations as Commander in
Chief I thank my own forces
my own command structure the military
men and women in uniform working with us
the civilians for one job only to
retrieve our brothers and sisters down
there heavy rains flooded the pit rescue
teams are trying to pump out the water
the unable ground is making search and
rescue efforts even more difficult
mutasa
alaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
is
zero